we have a voicemail number which is two
one nine two David P I love this
voicemail this is a delightful caller
who thinks Trump may have lied about how
great he is for black Americans take a
listen to this one of my new favorite
callers well I am definitely going to
vote for vice president body with all
Americans need to go out there and vote
for November the third yes we need to
get that dangerous person out of the
White House he's very dangerous and he
is the laziest president if we Pele
he said he's done more for black people
than any president he told a lie that's
right
which we all know how lies we do and of
course always welcome the David Pakman
show playing in the background while the
caller leaves a voicemail yes you are
completely right Donald Trump's claims
about how great he's been for black
America is that their claims that that
are a joke we've debunked them
individually we've got to get him out it
is more or the last 48 hours and what
happened at the rally have renewed the
urgency of removing this guy on the
bonus show today by the way another
reason to get him out Donald Trump has a
new plan for ending daca last week the
Supreme Court rejected Trump's argument
for why daca should be cancelled and we
said he's going to try it again and he
may win if he tries it again there is a
plan that could take six months to
complete Trump will still be in office
in six months but oh wait no no yes
March
did December yeah he will still be in
office in six months but he will be
close to out if if if if we replace him
in November by voting for Joe Biden and
no surprise that there is a new plan
will tell you what it is to get rid of
daca on the bonus show we will also talk
about the project to map the ocean floor
very interesting science project and and
I'll tell you why it matters and we will
also tell you the latest coronavirus
shortage we had toilet paper we then had
bicycles
it is now coins coins and I will explain
why become a member and get instant
access at join PAC
dot-com